monica is doing dancing with the stars
how do you think
she would fare on the show very used to
walking in heels already
either of you guys approached
i just want to know how you guys are
doing quarantine
this pandemic we're living in in kind of
wild times right now
lexi you want to go first yeah um
so pretty much like our whole
um way we run things over here at
navarro is
way different but i mean it's all to
make sure like everyone is safe
and like um not spreading any germs
we have to wear masks to practices and
we're actually practicing in
small groups so that like people don't
like mesh
together and like spread germs we're not
even outside of practice like we're
supposed to stay
like with our groups if we do like hang
out with anyone
and um that's gonna go on for a little
bit and
eventually like we'll work our way back
into like everyone getting to be
together again
and we're all just like waiting for that
moment that's crazy so you guys are both
like
actively in school right now both
practicing with navarro
and that's just the way that life goes
so what lexi was saying
we're basically having to do like you
know kind of
precautions and go it's we're all
just kind of planning by year like
because i feel like things are
constantly changing so
we go we take each week by week so
uh we're doing really really well though
getting a lot done
and we're doing it really safely so
everything's looking really good over
here but it's still we're still
able to thankfully practice together
because our sport is
a you know interactive sport
we're having to you know be be up each
other's
you know in each other's faces
how's that gonna work but we're making
it work so everything is doing really
really well the team's good
and uh i'm really excited because we get
to reunite with our team like
our whole team in about a week or so wow
are you guys preparing for a specific
competition right now
we have daytona which everybody knows
from
uh the show and basically we train all
year long
for one competition and we'll have like
show-offs
right before daytona but that's the main
goal so
daytona is in end of march beginning of
april
falls around that time so right now
we're just really really training for
that and hoping that everything runs
smoothly and
that there will be a daytona for this
next upcoming season
how do you guys yeah seriously how do
you guys practice with masks on
and like have you had to get tested at
all
so for us right now we
are we do not get koba tested unless
someone is showing symptoms which
everybody right now
is perfectly healthy okay and uh we're
all doing super super good we've been
given rules and regulations to follow
so uh until someone starts showing
symptoms
they get quarantined and then everybody
that has been around that's why we're
putting
getting put in groups are you guys
confident that daytona will happen
i'm gonna speak it into existence and
manifest it into reality because
honestly it was really heartbreaking for
it to like be canceled last year
and we're just gonna hope that
it doesn't like happen again and that we
get to do what we
came here to do yeah are there cameras
following you guys right now
[Music]
um right now we're just happy to be here
[Laughter]
i like the kg response i do want to talk
about what you guys are doing this
weekend
with athleta girl gonna do this sort of
virtual event so sort of tell me what
fans who join can expect and why you
wanted to be
part of this so i'm very very
uh excited because although sports are
on pause
due to covid athletic girl is putting on
an interactive hour session of
just you know a good good little workout
and getting everybody to move and just
you know be normal and
be athletic yeah i'm excited i hope that
it'll like inspire some people
to like you know get up and get active
because
you know whenever you're in a state of
like you know
being used to like being able to do
everything that we were doing before
corona
it can be like really like kind of
almost depressing whenever you like
don't get to do any of those stuff
anymore and i mean i experienced the
same thing whenever
we um had to you know pack our bags and
leave navarro because of corona and
you know sitting around for so long gets
like really exhausting and sometimes
it's hard to find like motivation like
to get up and active so like
i hope that me and gabby can actually
like inspire some people to like you
know
you know have the motivation to get up
and get moving with us
very exciting time for cheer because you
guys also got six
emmy nominations which is amazing i mean
how did you
a react to that news
i was so like excited about it i was
like
not expecting it to like go that far at
all
and so whenever i found out i was like
oh my god
yeah this is crazy like i was
in something that like went this far and
like
everyone else i'm around is like
probably feeling the same thing like
this is crazy
um it's funny because kind of what the
same thing lexi was saying you know
when you're filming something you don't
see the magic behind it
until it's complete like you know you're
like oh yeah we're getting filmed but
like
you don't see what's actually happening
behind the scene and like
you know i think when they were filming
i i could tell like just
the way that we were doing things that
it was going to be something special
but of course like you don't really see
the full effect until you sit back and
you're like oh
you finally get to see it right but it's
definitely very
very flattering like just to get one is
hard
so that the fact that we got six i mean
no one knew that it was gonna be like oh
like
this show is gonna be i knew
that the show was going to be as good as
we thought like
and now you know looking back when we
first
started filming we were like who would
have thought that we would be sitting
here later with six
you know emmy nominations it's just
insane
have you guys made a plan to film a
group
acceptance speech if you guys win yeah
so we've been uh
we've been uh kind of just on the
you know we we're just kind of like
waiting that for them to direct us what
to do but
uh i think lexi can agree we're just
kind of playing it by ear
so yeah could you guys pre-tape a
performance
is that being talked about
honestly i'm not entirely sure exactly
what we're gonna be doing but um
whatever's asked of us
i'm confident that we'll put it together
in a very like
um very well thought out way okay
a performance for the taping would be um
a pretty fun idea
so so that's how we put on a show
is that what you guys are really
practicing for right now
yeah girl we we we have so many things
like that we're juggling right now
monica is doing dancing with the stars
how do you think she would do
just because she's so used to being the
coach and now
she'll have a partner sort of leading
things with her determination
she could become a pro at anything like
if if i
can like um see her doing a back
walkover
in high heel boots then i know she can
do anything like
she'll be fine she'll get other great
honestly used to walking in heels
already
like i feel like she's a really hard
worker and she is a coach
and she also sees a side of like
you know because she did cheer back in
the day like
so i think that she can take good
criticism
and i feel like she's a hard worker so i
think that she would kill it
yeah she definitely will kill it would
either of you guys ever do dancing with
the stars
maybe honestly i wanted to like
like if i did learn dancing i kind of
want to learn how to do like
hip hop dancing i feel like that would
be like super fun
yeah um i don't know about like um
formal dancing i can't even wear heels
either of you guys approached oh gabby
you were
yes yeah do you
have to turn it down
[Music]
i mean girl i keep it low-key
but i mean whatever happens in the
future i feel like
it will be you know seen but i would
love to do it i think it'd be a really
really
amazing experience just because i feel
like
first of all i'm an athlete so i mean
i'm super competitive
in nature and also i do think that
it's funny my grandma she's colombian
and
she loves dancing like me and her watch
dancing with the stars all the time like
i'll go over to her house
and she just loves it she's like the way
they move their hips it's just
amazing it's so good i'm like and it
just sounds funny because you know i
feel like
i've always wanted to learn how to dance
so i think it'd be an amazing experience
maybe next year
and then i know you guys don't really
know yet but
is there a slight chance that a season
two
following you guys could ever
potentially
maybe happen
i'm just happy to be here
anything is possible so i mean yeah
i know it's hard to be like because
you're so anxious but
don't worry everything whatever happens
is gonna happen
and it's anything is possible so what's
meant to be will be